[Music]
you know I've been learning a great deal
about Atlanta since I got here a couple
days ago for example I didn't realize
just how much television is produced in
this great city Walking Dead produced
here Tyler Perry's House of Payne
family feud's pretty tear I just
[Music]
[Applause]
I'll help you okay I didn't even see you
up there man I'm sorry look dude we mean
you no trouble
but since crawling with walkers out
there do you mind if we hang out here
for a little bit please please we're
good people sure you can hide from
zombies here if you want that's fine
zombies you mean like walkers yeah
thanks buddy
I swear I swear you won't even know that
we're here and we can help with chores
okay good at other things too all right
that's fine let's find pal as I was
saying okay just hang out here and we'll
do the show ladies and gentlemen as I
was saying our show is especially great
well because there's so many great times
you just shot my cameraman
I'm sorry with the Walker and you killed
my basketball stunt double
hey bro I'm sorry I thought that was you
all right you guys need to calm down all
right
just calm down now as I was saying we
got a real peach of a show tonight right
right
a real Georgia Peach of a show you just
shot Andy in the chest what the hell was
that what do you mean what was that that
was just a bad joke
he's got a point look pal I'm trying to
do a show okay oh you're trying to do
what show is that right well you know
what if this is your idea of a show I
guess we're gonna just have to take our
chances out there with the walkers what
do you say about that
[Applause]
that woman
I'm really sorry everybody Andy are you
okay
yeah I've been dead inside for years